okay welcome everyone this is going to
be a relatively short webinar today the
introductory slide there gives you our
standard information maybe one of the
most important things is feel free to
ask questions in the question pod during
the webinar as you think of those
questions we always have the questions
and answers in a materials link on the
courses and webinars page and the
archived webinars just search NCBI
courses and webinars and you'll find
that page and within a few days this
webinar which is being recorded will be
on our YouTube channel along with the
others please feel free to email me
directly if you have questions afterward
Matson at NCBI NLM NIH gov and of course
send general blast questions - last -
help at NCBI domain and sitting here
with me today is Christian Camacho and
Tom Madden developers from the blast
group so you'll get some very expert
answers to your questions Peter Cooper
is on the question pod answering
questions during the webinar so let me
go ahead and give you the take home
message for today so the take-home
message is we highly encourage you to
upgrade to version 2.5 point o before
November 9th and the next slide will
tell you what's going to happen on
November 9th so the first of the topics
today has to do with an ncbi wide switch
to http from standard HTTP but this will
particularly affect standalone blasts in
a couple ways that I'll show you on the
next slide this a change is going to
take effect for api's on November 9th
that deal with blast the general web
pages at NCBI have already made this
change I'll also talk a bit about
another NCBI wide change which is the
phasing out of GI numbers and how using
accession dot version will impact
standalone blast and then very briefly
touch on a couple other improvements
that came out in this release so what's
going to break on November 9th if you
are still using version 2.4 0.0 or
earlier primarily the remote option in
other words if you send searches to our
servers using
the remote option that will fail to work
unless you have upgraded to two point
five point Oh on November 9th another
function some of you may or may not be
using but it's very handy and that is a
pre fetch function in the past in other
words in previous versions you could
only use that with the remote option but
in this version it's been improved and
you can use that without the remote
option so what happens is you input a
query file that contains identifiers
either gi's or accessions and the
programs will fetch those IDs from NCBI
to get the sequence records so you will
not be able to use these two functions
if you have not upgraded before November
9 now having said that we plan to have a
test this coming Thursday October 13th
from 10:00 a.m. to 11:00 a.m. Eastern
Time in other words you know try running
version 2.4 point O and it should not
work during that time but two-point 5.0
should we may very well have other tests
before the ninth we probably will before
November 9 and look on our webpages for
an announcement of those tests hopefully
we can get an announcement out in the
blast announce email list for those
other upcoming tests ok so the second
major change has to do with phasing out
of GIS and I've got a couple links on
the last couple slides where you can get
more general information about both the
HTTP change and the phase-out of GIS but
in terms of standalone blast what's
going to happen is you'll be seeing more
and more the new style of definition
line versus the old style so in the old
style definition line starts with GI and
then a pipe symbol and then the number
and so on we're moving now to just what
we call bear accession dot version as
you see in the new style now those of
you who are downloading our fast a
databases from the blast FTP site have
already noticed this
we've already switched over to the
accession dot version definition lines
but there are other places where this
will become more apparent in standalone
blast for example and
tbh command if you retrieve sequences
from our pre-formatted databases that is
those one directory up from fast a the
default setting for returning fast day
will fit out the new style format in
other words accession dot version you
may see on my example command line here
I've used an accession you can still use
GI numbers as input to Blas TB command
but you'll get back
by default this accession dot version
format some other changes and make Blas
TB it's been improved so it will accept
both the old and new style definition
lines so you don't have to worry about
changing everything just yet
it will also guess the source from the
accession alone if you're using parsec
IDs and I assume that would be primarily
with our pre formatted databases also
many of you use the GI list option to
create a custom database say to an
organism or taxonomic group that GI
lists which is still available and will
remain available but we also have a seek
ID list option so that seek ID list
option will take the accession dot
versions it's a bit slow with large
lists right now but that's going to be
improved in future releases we hope by
the next release if not the one
following that the next release by the
way is to point 6.0 and as of today
that's scheduled to come out either in
December of this year perhaps early next
year ok couple other changes in the
default output format so those of you
using the tabular output formats you're
now going to get by default query
accession sequence accession as shown
here in other words the accession
numbers in the next release you'll be
getting accession dodging so you will
not be getting back by default the GI
style definition lines ok so that's
those are the two major changes one of
the improvements we've made is to offer
another output format option and that's
output
format option 18 will now give you a
taxonomy organism report so if you're
familiar with using this on the web it's
similar and look to that very nicely
organizes the output by organism as you
see in this example and finally in terms
of improvements we now have included
composition based statistics when you
use RPS T blast n you're not familiar
with that program this allows you to
input a nucleotide sequence it does the
translations and searches against the
conserved domain database you get back
conserved domains not bet back
RPS blast as some of you may know allows
you input a protein sequence and see
what conserved domains are there our PST
blast n allows you to input a nucleotide
sequence ok so I promised a couple links
so you can go to our news page to find
out about the general GI number
phase-out and go to our home page in the
developed section and then the API
section you can read about the switch to
HTTPS and for full discussion of the
release notes go to the NCBI bookshelf
you can just search NCBI bookshelf blast
and you'll get these release notes
written by Christiaan so I'm going to
open this up for any questions I'm gonna
check out our chat pod here see if we've
had any questions come in ok we're not
seeing any questions at the moment thank
you very much and we will see you at the
next webinar
you